euclid lava chest
i'm going to show you another face this
time this one you're going to recognize
though
okay so hooray right you recognize this
guy i'm pointing at einstein for two
reasons number one okay you can see
you can see he's gone a little further
in time right we're now getting into the
20th century okay in fact uh you know by
the time he hit the 20th century he was
like 21 years old and he was about to
make all of his major contributions to
science the reason why he's famous okay
uh but you may not know uh
he started in germany yeah he started in
germany
he went to the us to do like academic-y
sort of stuff because you know he's
einstein but
when he left
this little thing started back home
called world war ii
and being that einstein was jewish
and germany wasn't really fans of they
weren't really fans of the jews at that
time
he never went back okay so that's why
the us is there
now that was the first reason i
mentioned so do you get you know i said
this is a global project no kidding
right
uh one of the wonderful things about
mathematics is it's a language that's
universal okay so greeks
and russians and
jewish germans they all contribute
now
the second reason i'm mentioning him to
you is because
he took this idea of lobochevsky
geometry and he said well you know
we live on a world
that is curved right it's it's a curve
but but but
does it not look flat
it looks flat right you look at it
you're like feels pretty flat to me okay
now
you can just see
from where we stand if you go to
somewhere where you can see the ocean
right you can just see just the
curvature of the horizon so you have
clues
but it looks flat okay now einstein said
if this world that we stand on looks
flat but really is curved does it not
stand to reason that other things which
kind of look flat
are actually
curved
right now one of the prime examples he
thought of was this thing right watch my
beautiful illustrations
okay now i have not finished yet
the moon
the stars
okay now
uh some of you have seen some of you
have seen your diagrams of the solar
system okay and you know they put out
the planets there and the distances are
completely ridiculous so that they can
make it reasonable right but one of the
interesting things which you might not
realize is that diagrams of the solar
system they often show things kind of
like this right you've got orbits of the
planets and they look like that and you
think well you know what it's not to
scale i know it's not meant to be the
scale maybe you know the planets don't
align like this but actually
when you look at the solar system and if
you traced out all their paths except
for a couple of unusual things actually
basically the solar system
is flat all the planets are on like this
flat sheet of paper right kind of stuff
right um there are some like minor
variations but basically
it looks flat now einstein said
sure it might look like that
but what if it's
not right and he tried to explain
gravity
yeah by saying well you know what i
think
gravity right when really heavy objects
exist like the sun right
what they do
is they curve
he didn't just say space he said space
and time
right time also feels flat we just go
along at you know
uh 60 minutes per hour that's the rate
we always go right well einstein said
what if it's not what if in fact the
earth itself is curving
space
right
so you can see this idea like a chance
he was like you know let's just see what
happens right this is an interesting
idea what if things aren't flat right he
wasn't thinking of this but einstein
said i think the universe is like this
okay so you see where this is going all
right now
i'm going to show you one more person
and then i'm going to try and update you
on today
now
his name is benoit mandelbrot okay uh
and you might be able to tell by the way
pronounce it and the way it's felt uh he
was french and polish okay ben one man
worked now
benoit meant a lot he said well
we've looked at this idea of flat space
that's what you could say this idea of
curved space that lobochevsky introduced
right
that's that's great that's that's really
helpful but it still doesn't really
capture everything for instance you know
uh we understand circles i drew one
right as like kind of these perfect
shapes but the reality is that there are
really no shapes that are perfect like
that they're kind of like that but
nothing's like that
it doesn't take that much looking around
for example
to see shapes like this okay
now
what is this this is satellite
photography okay um basically we're
looking at a river delta okay you've got
like the ocean over here right and this
is the place where the ocean is meeting
land in many places of the world when
the ocean meets land this is what
happens and then what said hold on
these are shapes clearly these are
shapes and you can almost see there's a
kind of structure here isn't it it's not
just like random or arbitrary there's a
pattern almost yeah that's right he said
is this geometry it's not this kind of
geometry
it's not really this kind of geometry
either like that shape i showed you a
lot of chess introduced it's curved
great but it's still very
precise and perfect
he said is this geometry too
he introduced a different kind of
junction we looked at flat geometry
right it's called
fractal geometry
uh like i said many people contributed
this but manure was one of the main
people who said look this kind of shape
here this shape
what it has is it represents something
called self-similarity right so if you
zoom in and zoom in like if you look at
a little portion here right this little
portion is kind of like a small version
of the whole thing it just branches out
and then it branches out again and you
can see the same kind of pattern in a
tree you can see the same kind of
pattern in a flower right they're just
the same thing but smaller it's more and
smaller
they're called fractals and he pushed on
the mass of this geometry and he made
shapes like this
all right
now this thing i want you to have a look
at it right
it's not art well kind of it's matte but
if you look further in right it's the
same shape over and over again you can
zoom in forever you just keep getting
the same shape this is a fractal in fact
this
is the manual broad fractal this is the
one named after him okay there are many
many different ones you should go just
go to google images just search the word
fractal okay sorry i'll do it i'll do
better than that i have the internet so
let's do this
okay so you've got all these weird
wonderful shapes that you can see let's
have a look at this one is that kind of
like fun uh yes yeah because the words
are the same kind of thing let's have a
look for example if i just pull up this
kind of thing
yes
have a look at this shape
have a look at it right this is a
fractal
it's not anything that you could or
lobochevsky could have imagined right
but clearly it shaped its geometry
now
let me finish by showing you i said this
project this geometry project that's
going over all of history and all of the
world is still happening
what's happening today uh hopefully
you'll recognize this yeah yeah uh when
uh when i went to school this is what i
learned that an atom looks like but some
of your science teachers might have
mentioned you know actually this is not
really what an atom looks like this is
kind of a rough idea and it's a helpful
illustration okay
now people are trying to understand what
is the real shape of reality down there
when you look at a really tiny object
right one of the things they've said is
that um you know
uh this lobby checks geometry right
versus euclid it kind of goes from two
dimensions flat
to three dimensions
right
which is not flat anymore now einstein
went further he said there's another
dimension which is
time which is the fourth dimension right
but these days over the last few decades
people said you know what
if you look at the maps of it
we think there are more than four
there are many different theories but
one of the examples
is that actually
get this
there are
22 dimensions now wow
how do you do the geometry with shapes
like that you can't even picture it but
that's not going to stop people
from trying
right well this
this what it does look 3d because that's
the world we inhabit
but there's this idea that it kind of
folds in on itself and it's this weird
almost impossible for humans to
comprehend
shape this is where geometry is going
today
right do you remember i said whoever i
said
coming back over here right
euclid said
this is this is the shapes there are
children learnt about these shapes for
centuries right but eventually we got to
the point where actually you know what
there's more than that right and we know
what 3d shapes are we know what 3d
shapes are we understand that
maybe
just maybe
by the time it gets to a few centuries
in the future when they say geometry
they're going to be looking at 22
dimensions
who knows the point is what are we going
to do as we start this topic
we are launching into this story okay